the jurgen experience so the intent of
plants is very clear here
it's saying if you eat too much of me
i'm going to affect your thyroid
negatively
and that's going to affect every other
hormonal system in your body
so yes sulforaphane can be beneficial
because it turns on our antioxidant
response system
but it also has many side effects which
are ignored and we see this pattern
over and over and over and this is what
was fascinating we see this pattern over
and over and over with plant molecules
and then if you look at these two people
might say well is the risk worth the
benefit
and i would argue it's not or i would
argue the benefit is not worth the risk
because you can get your nrf2 system
turned on
without those molecules because you can
do environmental hormesis
you can go in the sauna you can exercise
you can fast
you can be in ketosis there's really
good studies
in cold water swimmers in berlin and
their show they show that cold water
exposure so they go
and they swim in cold water for like an
hour and they'll show that their
glutathione level
goes down meaning that they their
oxidized level of glutathione goes up
the reduced level of glutathione goes
down
they're using their endogenous
antioxidant molecule one of them which
is glutathione
to mitigate these newly produced
oxidative radicals these free radicals
in the human body
produced by cold water swimming and then
the next day they'll see their
glutathione is a little bit above normal
that's hormesis that's environmental
hormesis so my argument is
can we really say that plant molecules
give us a net benefit
i don't think we can there's lots of
interesting studies here that would
argue that
we don't really get a net benefit from
plant molecules it's kind of a redundant
effect we can get
this nrf2 system this antioxidant
response system turned on without them
and then we're getting all of the
downstream negative side effects of
these plant molecules have there been
any independent studies that show
people taking like broccoli sprouts and
then doing it for a prolonged period of
time measuring their system
and then doing environmental hormesis
and seeing if they
they measure up well there's actually
studies that show
they have two groups of people and i can
pull these up if you want there are
studies that compare people
that ate essentially no vegetables or
low fruits and vegetables to high fruits
and vegetables
and they'll compare them at 4 8 or 12
weeks
and at the end they see no differences
in the oxidative stress markers the
inflammatory markers
markers of dna damage so it's pretty
shaky ground to say that invariably all
the studies of fruits and vegetables
show that they provide this benefit in
the short term
sulforaphane can create more
antioxidant response you get more
glutathione but if you take it out a
little bit of time
it doesn't look like there's any
difference between people who are eating
things like
broccoli or jerusalem artichokes or
carrots or cabbage or any other
vegetables
compared to a group that eats none of
them so there's these fruit and
vegetable intervention studies which
don't show any differences between these
people
that's bananas so all the people that
are thinking that they're
doing a good thing for their system by
taking these
vegetables and fruits that have this
horm your body has this hermetic
response
for you can have the exact same response
from cold plunge from sauna from
exercise you're turning on the exact
same system in your body
but what about the vitamins that you're
getting from plants
right there are there there are
essential nutrients and phytonutrients
that you get from plants
what about those so this is really
interesting when you look into it
there are really this is going to sound
extreme when i say it but i'll back it
up there are
no nutrients in plants that you cannot
get from animal foods
in essentially equivalent or more
bio-equivalent forms
how come when like cats eat an animal
they go for the guts first and
they'll actually eat the grass that's in
the guts of the cow
i don't know the guts of a room in it i
don't know why they would do that i
guess it's fermented
i don't know because if you look at the
nutrients
in um in animal foods right
there are many nutrients and animal
foods that do not occur in plants
and we know this b12 but the list is
much bigger vitamin k2 choline
carnosine carnitine anserine taurine
the list is extremely long but you can't
say the same thing about plants there
are no nutrients that are current plants
that you can't get from animal foods
none vitamin c you can definitely get
vitamin c from animal foods and you get
it from what do you get from liver
liver heart muscle it all has vitamin c
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love